start hi everybody um I'm Val uh I am a
contributor to metaflow and I work at
outer bounds where we offer like a
managed metaflow based solution now my
talk like actually all the words written
in the title over here are something
that I looked up online and I could not
find anywhere else that these words are
used together and what I wanted to say
is that like to actually explain why
this is important why multiplayer
machine learning is important it is
important for me to explain why is it
suddenly become like so important and
what makes it challenging and once I
give that bit of a premise I can like
dive deeper into like what is metaflow
and how it will help in solving such
multiplayer machine learning problems
while also at the end showing like a
tiny demo on like how you could do it
practically um so why is it suddenly so
important now one cool thing that has
happened over the past decade is that
machine learning has really really grown
fast and what it means is that like just
10 years ago we were like barely able to
like identify cats and now you have like
chat Bots that are talking to like real
humans and like actually it's seems a
bit dystopian but like even people
creating images that are like semi-real
like you would not be able to
distinguish if it's like a fake or not
right and this entire wave of ml
progress in research has also like
trickled down in like towards the public
where over the past 10 years like the
amount of interest that the public has
in machine learning has also grown and
likewise like even the money that is
getting funneled into machine learning
in terms of Investments has also grown a
lot now the thing is that even though so
much money and so much interest is there
it is still a challenging Endeavor to
like actually build machine learning
systems and there are many forms of
complexities that come when you actually
go build out these systems some of these
complexities may be on the actual
software side on like how you build the
software and some of the complexities
are actually on just operating it and
building it with other people within
your
organization so like let's take a look
of at a few of these okay so first off
like the Deep learning revolution has
shown one thing which is like you can
like shove tons of data at a model and
it will like perform even better and
better as you throw more data or you
grow the model bigger and bigger so in
general like if you want want to solve
many of these like tough scalable like
tough problems in ml it requires that
you are able to like do tons of
computation in a reliable Safe Way all
right such that it is uh like it can
cost a lot more money to even do that uh
additionally it's like when you build ml
software it's actually very different
from like normal software normal
software like errors out like if you
have some weird input that you had never
like figured how to deal with in your
function your function would just like
cry and fail with ML it's weird because
it's like you can give an input that
your models never seen before and it
would give an output that you had never
thought of like handling before right so
like even handling bugs in general in
machine learning is like really really
complex and hard and many times like you
would not even realize
that your model's buggy CU you might
have trained it on like bad data and it
just went through cuz for you you just
saw that oh the training finished it's
working now uh the other side of this
which is outside the complexities of
just building ml software is that when
you work in an organization or in a team
people generally have like some form of
integration into their own
infrastructure into their own clouds and
in general like just wrangling around
Cloud infrastructure is hard like as you
can see from this diagram like AWS or
any other cloud provider that you go to
has like this so many services that play
with each other that like people just
get overwhelmed in like thinking about
okay what do I do just to do like a
simple hello world and additionally like
when you work in an org you the org
generally has their own data and like
their their own processes and pipelines
around how that data is created managed
all of that now the thing is that at the
end of the day when you are trying to do
machine learning in an org you have to
integrate into the same into that same
hose of data that is there and that can
become astonishingly difficult based on
the way General organizations even set
up their data
practices additionally like a lot of ml
happens in Python
and python in my opinion is a terrible
language with like not terrible language
but sorry it has a terrible dependency
management stack right and in general
like if you go through actually like and
based on like the way python works with
like the operating system there are like
so many dependencies that may not be
even in piie or
like you'll have to actually download
binaries for that and that becomes like
real really really hard as uh you want
to do it like that becomes really really
hard when you try to do it again and
again the other thing is that when
people work in an org with like multiple
data scientists or machine learning
Engineers everybody has their own
preferences on how they want to train
stuff so like somebody would come up and
say that oh I found like the newest
latest greatest llama model and I want
to use that someone else might say no no
no I want to use like the traditional
machine learning techniques that were
there to solve this problem so like
different people can have different
approaches that they would want to take
and it it becomes really hard when you
want to collaborate and coordinate
amongst all these people who want to
apply those different techniques right
um and finally it's like if generally in
an or people want to do machine learning
again and again and what it means is
that if my code ran once I want it to
run again
deterministically that like it should
not have like weird dependency issues
that if I try to rerun it the second
time my code will behave differently and
like if that become like if that
actually starts happening that the code
behaves differently based on like you
running it again and again then like
it's not reliable so overall like
reproducibility of experiments is as
important especially when you're working
like in a business in or organizational
setting and when we like bundle all of
these problems together right it
literally becomes like a death by a
Thousand Cuts where like solving one
individual piece of all of these
problems may be relatively simple but
like when you try to solve them all
together it is like really really
hard and this is where I wanted to
introduce the work we have been doing
around metaflow so metaflow is a open-
source software package that will uh
that is used by data scientists and
machine learning Engineers to scale and
manage the data science and machine
learning projects the way we see
metaflow is that in general the machine
learning like in general data scientists
or ml Engineers care more about the
actual modeling bits of their code like
they actually want to build good models
that can work and that that like deliver
business value but they actually care
less about where it's running like what
kind of infrastructure it's using you
know but in reality the need is such
that the infrastructure part is really
hard and it is super important and it's
like so that's why it's like uh this
stack is a way we try to explain what
metaflow does so the idea is that
metaflow tries to abstract away a lot of
the intricacies and nuances of the
interest structure around like actual
compute where you store your data how
your data gets stored all of that so
that the actual data scientists can just
focus on the important core logic parts
of the machine learning pipeline that
they're
building um the way metaflow works is
that it integrates into like various
services and orchestrators so that like
data scientists don't need to like know
the intricacies of all these different
systems file they can just work with
this one unified API now I've been
showing this stack and like all these
figures so I would rather want to do one
thing that like I would just want to
show you guys how like as a data
scientist you may start from a notebook
and how the entire progression can
happen into metaflow and then finally
move on to like actually showing you
guys different patterns in which you can
like you can build machine learning
pipelines with metaflow while
collaborating with with multiple
developers and also reacting like uh
training models on fresh data so let's
start with a simple thing that okay
you're playing around in a notebook
you're you written some code to okay you
want to train the model you get some
results by testing it you're seeing it
you see oh this is great this works so
now what what do we do
so we move this code from The Notebook
into to like a metaflow based flow so
what metaflow does is that it ex uh it
exposes this flow speec class and uh
what like what any developer would do is
that it would they would inherit this
flow speec class to Define their entire
machine learning pipeline uh it also
exposes a step decorator so any form of
step in your pipeline uh can be
annotated with a step decorator and then
the interdependencies between the steps
can be set via self. nextt within your
function and anything that you now set
to self which is the special python
variable will be version controlled
automatically so what it means is that
if you train a model and the model that
you get that you set to self over here
is now automatically version controlled
for you so that you can access it much
later on or even in the future so um Let
me Give an example of what I mean by
accessing it later so like let's say I
ran this flow and I got this model as
the output or like I set the model into
self over here now I can actually access
that same model object later in the
future whenever I want to and do
whatever I want with it so like once it
has been version controll uh every time
you execute
metaflow uh sorry yeah once it has been
version controlled when you execute
metaflow as you see over here when I say
python my flow.
pyun uh you can access it via the
metaflow client
API oh
sorry that you see over here where the
run is like an object that we expose
which uh which explains the
instantiation of a flow and what I mean
by instantiation is that when you're
actually executing it the final outputs
can be through this run object or this
flow
object and so every time one more key
thing is that every time you execute
it's like you're minting a new run ID
which is like an identifier for your
execution so like everything is then
namespaced on all the artifacts that are
created are namespaced under this that
run ID or of that
execution so now that we have a flow
that is working on my local machine I
want to make it Reliant enough that I
can reproduce it again and again so one
way I can do it is by just freezing
dependencies so metaflow exposes these
uh cond and piy based decorators that
hook into like cond and piy package
repositories and you can like just slap
one of these decorators on the flow and
set whatever libraries and versions that
you need for those libraries and all of
those code packages will automatically
get stored and be used when you're act
when you're actually executing all these
steps so if the train model function is
using psychic learn underneath then it
will actually just use 1.1.2 version of
psychic learn when the train model
function is
running um now now that we've Frozen
dependencies and we have like a good
idea of like our flow is running
properly and we are able to like get our
results on our laptops now what I want
to do is I want to actually throw more B
compute at it okay like I want to scale
it up throw tons of memory even a few
gpus if I can and this is where like I
think the real magic of metaflow starts
to appear so what meta So Meta
integrates into these various compute
mediums like kubernetes AWS batch and
for Simplicity sake the way I would want
to explain kuber for this talks context
is that imagine it's just this giant
cluster of servers that is seen as this
one unit so like if you are trying to
like uh deploy something where you need
specific amounts of memory CPU whatever
you can just tell kubernetes that okay I
have this definition of a job I want to
deploy it and I want so and so CPU and
memory and kubernetes will figure out in
where to place that job within the
entire cluster
so the way metaflow works with
kubernetes is that when a user is
running a flow by calling my flow. py
run we actually save all the code that
you have written on like that is going
to run on some artifacts like in some
data store like AWS S3 GCS whichever
cloud provider you hooked into and then
it'll actually launch jobs on kubernetes
when you while using the same code that
got stored earlier so giving an
example uh now that I want to scale out
I can like just slap this kubernetes
decorator and I can say how much memory
I want or how much CPU or how many gpus
I want and automatically metaflow will
actually put that the actually run this
step this start step inside kubernetes
with like a job sorry with a job with uh
6 4 GB of memory which is pretty cool
now now that I've scaled out and I know
that I am able to like run my code on
like a remote uh setup I want to make it
run autonomously that I want my code to
run regularly on some Cadence where I
don't have to like manually go punch
buttons to like start it or do stuff
with it so additionally this is where I
want to come to this whole concept of
deployments in metaflow that once you
have like done your prototyping and you
want to deploy it autonomously metaflow
integrates into these various schedulers
or orchestrators like Argo workflows
Apachi airflow um AWS step functions and
what these orchestrators basically help
do is that they will help run your code
without you having to like manual Press
buttons to do it so in this case uh for
kubernetes metaflow integrates into this
uh tool called Argo workflows and Argo
provides a way that once you deploy this
flow onto Argo all the code would have
been persisted before and when you would
have scheduled the flow to execute Argo
will automatically execute that flow and
everything in metaflow that I just
spoked about earlier like your
dependency management your versioning
your compute specification all of that
would be working in tandem with uh your
deployment so like if I and then the way
I can do these deployments is that it
exposes more decorators so like you have
a schedule decorator for example so when
you run this command mylow dopy Argo
workflows create it will actually
schedule a this workflow on Argo where
for example the start step will run with
like 64 gigabyt of memory and it will
run daily on its own because now your
dependencies are frozen so like you can
basically get a deterministic way that
your code will run without having any
failures um now deployment has many
fascinating patterns because people
would want that okay I want to run
something daily or weekly but sometimes
you want to react to different kinds of
events that are happening so that based
on that you would want to trigger some
form of training or do something
so metaflow exposes this notion of
events where let's say you have uh like
you have new data that is available you
emit an event the event gets caught by
Argo it triggers the training flow the
training flow created some model
artifacts it raises another event that
triggers an inference flow and then the
inference is done and like the same
inference flow is going to use whatever
model that got created in the training
flow so um and the way we actually
expose the events on the metaflow side
is using these decorators called trigger
on or trigger on finish now what does
trigger on do is that it will subscribe
this metaflow flow to this data. prep
event for example and what that means is
that you go and say that okay my flow.
Pi Argo workflow is cre
it deployed this in Argo workflows and
it told Argo that okay when you get the
data. prep event is when you need to
start executing this flow right
here
and additionally what we've also done is
that you can actually stitch together
different entire flows instead of even
just listening to like individual events
so for example this data prep flow that
you see over here uh was an upstream
flow flow that finishes that will raise
an event that I as data prep flow have
finished you can start executing now the
train model flow so like you can
actually stitch together separate flows
that you write in metaflow and they can
all be stitched together through this
whole Eventing mechanism where they'll
all execute asynchronously once
individual flows complete uh finish
execution um now now that we' talked
about events and like deployment
patterns and everything I think like I
want to now come to the core Crux of
this stock which is around multiplayer
machine learning and like how to like
collaboratively build all these models
now one key aspect to think about
especially with with regards to
multiplayer machine learning is that
whoever is doing any form of deployment
you don't want to step on your co-worker
shoes and what it means is that like if
I go build some model I don't want that
if my my coworker has also built
something that I actually like uh I his
work gets invalidated or like his
executions get like stepped on and like
my executions take over his execution so
like we want a way where all of us can
like me and all my co-workers can like
deploy
stuff
without it interfering with each other
and so like the ideal scenario would be
like if Alice tries to deploy something
thing then Alice gets a separate
execution and if Bob tries to deploy
something Bob also gets an entirely
separate execution where both of their
same like both of them are trying to
execute the same flow but they are going
to get separate instances that need to
get
executed and this is where uh I would
bring like there is this concept in
metaflow called projects that you can
add a project decorator to this flow and
anytime any user now starts executing
something or like anytime a user tries
to like run something or deploy
something uh it will be namespaced under
that user so that means if I as valet
try to execute this flow whatever
objects that are created as a part of
this flow will be namespaced under for
like will be namespaced under me so if
Alice executes this flow she can
actually write as you see over here an
ALICE model right where Alice may have
her own special model that she's
building and she's testing on so so if
Alice and Bob both are executing this
flow Alice and Bob will both have
separate execution instances they will
have completely separate data artifacts
that get created a part of this flow so
giving an example um this is Alice sorry
this was Alice executing now this is Bob
executing and as you see like these bold
arrows are trying to show what
effect do do these different decorators
have on the entire stack so for example
Bob's model will be versioned separately
from Alice's model and like even the
deployment that Bob will do will be done
will be completely separate from Alice's
deployment and uh yeah as I explained
like it will even work for deployments
where you can put the schedule you can
even like you can even hook it up to
like events separately so like you can I
have this data prep event over here I
can like uh like my actual sorry Bob's
actual deployment will be hooked up to
the data prep event and so if Alice
wants separate event to like be hooked
up she can literally write a separate
event name over here and it'll just be
hooked up to that event and it will not
step over Bob's work um so additionally
metaflow has this concept of branches is
in a project so like if people want to
do oneoff executions to like test stuff
they can like actually create like a
branch and what I mean by a branch is
that on the command line you just
provide an additional argument saying
that this is my new branch that I want
to test on and boom It'll like run a
separate execution everything will be
namespaced under that
Branch a second
yes so now comes like the real meat of
the talk which is like how do you train
on fresh data and basically how do you
do this reactive form of machine
learning and based on all of the things
that I just said earlier uh one key
thing like this the smallest explanation
I want to give here is that if you want
to train on fresh data constantly events
are an excellent mechanism to help
enable you to do that where anytime new
data is created you you can just raise
an event and then the event can get get
get caught by Argo in metaflow and
everything will start working on its own
additionally if multiple people are
trying to like uh train models on like
fresh data project the projects the
project decorator that I just talked
about earlier is like excellent means to
like name space all your events your
deployments and the data artifacts
created from that so let's go through
some use cases okay where I had two
major use cases in mind where users are
actually controlling the data that they
are using for their models versus a use
case where users have no control of that
data data is prepared by completely
someone else they just want to actually
train on whatever they're getting so
let's take the first one where users are
not managing any form of data creation
so the simplest thing to do in this form
of scenario
is that both Alice and Bob will listen
to the same event and when that event is
raised both Alice and Bob's uh machine
learning pipelines will start getting
executed so uh giving an example this is
Alice's model where she has set trigger
on to the data prep event and in the
same way this is Bob's model and Bob's
flow where they have like
He Set uh a subscription on the data
prep event and as you will see like both
of these flows once they are deployed on
kubernetes and Argo they will run as
separate instances when that event is
raised now let's take the second case of
where
users uh like where users want to manage
their own data they want to make their
own data they want to set up everything
on their own and they even want to like
raise their own events right and this is
where the whole idea of projects and
name spaces like really really shines
because the really cool thing with
metaflow is that if Alice has some flow
which is raising an event on its
completion that event itself is
namespaced to Alice's work so what that
means is that that event will only be
caught by any flow that has been
subscribing uh so any flow that has been
deployed by Alice and no one else so the
good bit about that is that if uh if I'm
experimenting with like multiple event
like if I'm experimenting over like
multiple flows that I'm stitching
together bya events and other people are
also working on those flows with
projects and Nam spaces you can actually
not like step on each other shoes and
there will be complete separate events
so like everybody can experiment however
they wish to
so uh an example over here is that like
let's say that there's this data prep
flow which is scheduled on a daily basis
it has a project decorator and like at
the end uh it just like creates a data
set and it validates it now when the
flow finishes execution on Argo it will
raise an event saying that I'm am done
as the data prep flow and the event
since it is
namespaced uh where like right now I'm
user Bob so if one second yes so since
the event is namespaced when you put the
trigger on finished decorator on this
flow uh and you say that okay I am
listening to the data prep flow then
only the execution of Bob's data prep
flow raising the event will actually
trigger the train model flow written by
Bob so if Alice has written a separate
flow like this like the train model flow
then Alice's execution won't stop start
only Bob's execution will start because
all the events have been names
based um actually yes now that I've
given everybody like a rundown of like
how these things can work like how
different use cases around managing or
like uh training on fresh data can be
handled I want to just dive into like
this tiny demo example that we've
created um so the idea was that okay I'm
working in an org there's like a team of
people who are like creating data sets
and like actually the demo is going to
be about the first use case uh and it's
actually not that hard to even Port it
to like the Second Use case but in this
demo the idea is that I am like there's
somebody who's creating the data and
when they create the data at the end
they're raising an Argo event um over
here one key Nuance is that uh I didn't
want to actually take data from places
so I'm just like Piggy backing of
hugging face Hub um but this is again
this is just a demo um now once the data
has been created um I want to actually
start training some like llama model on
this new data and that's majorly it so
how do we do that like you raise an
event that is the main connective tissue
between these two flows so let me get
into
it second
yes um
so okay
perfect so let's say
uh my terminals as you see there's an
ALICE there's a bob and this is a data
prep so let me just set up some data
prep first so as you see I will first
deploy the data prep onto
Argo and as you see it is bootstrapping
virtual environment
and now it has been deployed I will
trigger it so that uh in just a bit just
to show you guys how like the execution
will turn out now uh I'll go to Bob's
flow
and um so all of this code is open
source by the way um it will be in the
slides if you guys are
interested so
perfect so I'll do as you see remote
outflow Argo workflows
create and as you see it has it is
saying this the first time I'm deploying
as Bob and it has now created like a
separate instance on Argo for Bob now
I'll do the same thing for
Alice so now it's doing the same thing
for Alice where as it is saying that the
workflow has will automatically trigger
when there's this event that gets raised
which is the alpaka do data prep event
so now both of my flows have been wired
up on Argo I can now actually trigger
the their execution via raising this
event so this data prep flow will now
raise an
event and based on that we will see the
execution of the other two flows
starting
too now the other cool bit with metaflow
is that it exposes this user interface
uh called the metaflow UI where you can
actually see and track all the
executions that are happening um one
second yes so uh in
the perfect yeah so in the past I had
like uh trained some of of these flows
before so as you can see this is how it
turns out like you can actually go in
spe you can actually see all the logs
that have been created as a part of your
execution and additionally metaflow has
this snifty little feature called cards
which inspires from this model cards
concept that was just that came around
when machine learning has grown um so as
you see this is like an entire descript
of what happened in the flow what kind
of parameters did it have any kind of
artifacts that got created as a part of
it and one
second so as you see this data prep flow
has started and it is
executing and once this will finish it
will raise an event that will trigger
the execution of this llama instruction
tuning flow so and you can see as you
see over here anytime time like you
create like anytime a flow get
instantiated from a separate event you
will get to see the event on the
metaflow
UI and as you see yeah over here Bob's
flow started
execution and so we alysis in just a bit
uh there's not enough compute capacity
I'm like throwing too many gpus at this
um
and to
include metaflow offers this way where
it holistically tries to integrate into
the entire machine learning
infrastructure stack uh so that data
scientists and machine learning
Engineers don't have to worry about like
the intricate nuances of the lowlevel
stuff and they can actually focus on
building their models and the higher
level stuff and thank you and if you
guys want to use metaflow uh for free we
have a Sandbox uh environment that has
all of this set up for you you don't
have to do anything you just have to
just visit the sandbox and play around
but yeah thank you so much
[Applause]
and